today's guest is an entrepreneur he's a
renegade he's a business moggle and he
is the head of the
UFC um he's from Massachusetts and I
couldn't be more excited to go a couple
rounds with someone uh today's guest is
Mr Dana
[Music]
White I'll sit and tell you my
stories
shine on
me and I will find a song
[Applause]
I do you feel handsomer as you've gotten
more in
shape you you guys got to deal with
Celsius yeah it's pretty good yeah it's
awesome man so um it's good man we've
had a really great year we've um it's
been fascinating man all types of just
interesting people rappers Robert F
Kennedy um we just had Wayne
Gretzky um I don't know who else we
gotta do Trump yeah we get closer I'll
get you Trump if you want to do them
yeah well we had sexy red on and she's
from the hood right she has some pretty
ratchet stuff she sings about like her
vagina stuff but people love her right
that's her yeah sexy red is wild she
yeah uh and she is actually pregnant as
well the best part of it was that the
end I was like Hey I'm going to invite
you to UFC fight sometimes she's like
I'd love to go that would be awesome so
the hood would really show up for that
what did you think about slap well it's
a great question brother um first of all
I didn't know I didn't know what being
there makes it you're like oh my God
this is amazing I like how it's bite
siiz in the way that if you want to like
hang out with friends and chat you can
be talking to your buddy and you know
exactly when the action is going to
happen
so where UFC you don't want
to good so I loved how it was like very
diges like okay it's like hold on dude
chill let's focus this is it um I like
the people that were there I thought was
really interesting I can't tell when I'm
there there's moments where I'm
supporting and then there's moments
where I'm heckling almost right there's
respect for sure but I could like I
don't know it was weird like cow like
cowboy Cerrone is there and he's like
knock him out them slides like one guys
wearing sandals you know so I think
there's a little bit of a peanut gallery
aspect there is um but there is at UFC
too though I mean there there's a lot of
lot of yelling and [__] talking at UFC I
think UFC has become a lot more
sophisticated over the like the last 10
years yeah but before that it was was it
really quite a slap crowd yeah oh well
dude I remember when I first heard about
UFC it was like the kids who were not
going to finish School were watching it
right it was like they had a VHS it
would like come in the mail that dude
exactly yeah dude that dude yeah that
dude talk about a guy that's become
famous just off [__] one picture of
sitting in the crowd um just bleed he
works with blood drives now too which is
crazy huh no are you serious no I'm not
but that would be yeah but that would be
actually it's not a bad partnership dude
I'd [__] I'd pour a 12 oz O Negative
for that guy if you asked me to that an
animal tell you something fascinating
about the slap content so there's a
there's a woman named Amy Kaplan and
she's she's a media member right and I
don't know who she writes for but she
comes to everything UFC slap she
supports whatever right so when she
showed up to slap on um on Wednesday she
had 20 followers on Tik Tok so she
posted the the the the video of Sheena
the women's one knocking her out right
now it's at 1.6 million views and she
has 36 00 followers off one post from
slab how crazy is that this is the one
right here yeah you should you should
have cut that up and put it out that's
all all the all the influencers that
come they love it because the content's
so powerful
oh listen to me if you take the NFL the
NBA Major League Baseball the NHL UFC
WWE NASCAR Formula 1 PGA and a couple
other ones you combine all their numbers
together on social multiply them by four
they don't do what power slap does no
way [__] fact and when when you post
this content it is unbelievably powerful
man yeah other things that I thought
really about it I liked how I wish I
knew some of the fighters better I know
some of that takes time and get you know
him right 100% this is only our fifth
ever event it's been around for eight
months and yeah no this thing's a
[__] Juggernaut though man but I dug
it dude I'm sitting there with my buddy
Sheldon Sor and uh we're like holy [__]
dude this is so much fun fun like I I
was like I was excited to come back it
it I'm not going to say it surprised me
but it did when the guy like almost got
a haircut off of his yeah he has that
beard you don't even know if he has a
chin you're like what if that dude
doesn't even have a chin and he's just
[__] out here that's one of the
things we've been talking about you know
it's some of these beards are so big
tell where the hell their face is I I
agree that's hilarious but I kind of
love that aspect of it it's a little bit
of camouflage dude where some guy rolls
out there with a naked chin some little
[__] nudist you know you're like this
guy's got to calm down this pervert puts
him grow a beard man did you did you
make it up to Red Rock after no I didn't
it was [__] Mayhem up there yeah we
go to the high limit room after and big
party up there at Red Rock after the
thing and everybody's gambling and all
this [__] but we had done this thing we
did a sweep Stakes where somebody would
get the opportunity to come and and
gamble with me and Steve will do it
right so we sit down at the table you
couldn't [__] write this you couldn't
write this sit down at the table I give
the guy five grand we start gambling and
he just leaves with it we start gambling
and uh me me and Hunter were just
talking about Hunter was his coach
Hunter was kind of coaching him over
there on the side and Hunter said the
guy was so nervous he's like you know at
one point he got up to what Hunter eight
grand wow he was up to $8,000 he had won
he was in the [__] perfect seat at
the table up to eight grand he's up to
nine grand now and and and I said listen
you don't have to stay here you can you
can leave whenever you want whatever
he's asking Hunter questions Hunter's
like Dana doesn't care if you want to
leave you you can quit when you want to
so he says okay this is my last bet then
Win Lose or Draw this is my last bet he
puts it up Steve will do it throws a
thousand up on it underneath the guy put
up like four or 500 Steve puts a
thousand under it he hits a [__]
Blackjack and wins I mean you couldn't
write a better [__] story than that
so the kid leaves there with almost 10
G's and uh you know won the sweep Stakes
come gamble with us and actually got the
experience slap got to go to the party
after and actually won 10 grand and win
wow yeah that's incredible I love doing
fun [__] like that yeah dude you know
what you do a great job of that I'll say
like I tune like and even now just being
in the facility and seeing like the
kitchen where you guys shoot the uh [__]
it Fridays and stuff I'm like man that's
pretty brave were you concerned about it
at all at first like just putting
yourself out there like that because I
think there's always this wall between
like is it you know when people step
into like putting themselves out in a
social media yeah no I I don't care I've
been doing it for so long I mean uh I
mean I was doing these video blogs
before this whole influencing thing was
a thing you know what I mean I used to
do video blogs on YouTube they would
follow us around in the plane going to
events and all the behind the scenes
type stuff so I I've been doing this for
a long time it doesn't bother me yeah
what um what kind of tunes do you listen
to what kind of music do you listen to
I'm into I'm into
so many different types of music I like
uh I mean my my all-time favorite bands
are Rage Against the Machine the Beasty
Boys and the Red Hot Chili Peppers um
but I listen to Everything I listen to
80s music listen to 70s music I listen
to uh rap I listen to you remember your
first concert you ever went to first
concert I ever went to is kind of weird
it was Berlin I went to Berlin it's a
band yeah oh yeah familiar with them
okay no more words you know oh yeah wait
no more words play A Beat of it
no more words no more words I'm thinking
of More Than Words I'm actually going to
the cult tonight Cults in town I'm going
to the cult and they're British huh yeah
oh
yeah you know the
C yeah kind of you know who I
[Music]
know who'd you go with I okay I get a
little bit of an energy now for what's
going on there will you stop it was
Michael bising the D you know he used to
be a DJ I didn't know that dude he has a
great story about uh somebody um stole
his records one night isn't this right
is Michael bisbing somebody stole his
records right he's the [__] DJ right
like the last guy you want to steal from
right some one guy some oneeyed [__]
you know Music Maniac running Skrillex
you know so he [__] F he F he finds
out who the dude is right the guy denies
it he pops the trunk and the records are
in the [__] tr dude and I think he
put the dude in the trunk did he really
I think that's how it ended but yeah uh
anyway he was a DJ but um no I wasn't
familiar with them my first I I I did
see Duran Duran recently though I did
too they were great yeah I thought it
was pretty good man they were great yeah
I I was very impressed with how good
they were I love live music so I go to
lots of concerts there's this there's
this kid so funny you say the cult I'm
going to the cult tonight I see the cult
all the time big cult fan too cult's one
of my favorite fans of all time so I uh
I I I go to the cult and some band
called Dez rocks is is opening for him I
never heard of them and uh so I said ah
let's just go walk around we'll come
back later I come back and they have a
couple songs left I was Blown Away
really by how good they were Rock I was
so blown away that I jumped on on a
plane the next day and saw him again in
San Diego yeah and I saw him in Utah now
most of the music that you see for UFC
and power slab is Dez rocks no way when
do the commercials like the commercials
and all the hype pieces I use his music
oh it's amazing man yeah he's he's
incredible he's playing the trador in La
uh next Sunday oh sweet I think I'll be
out there then let's go you're gonna go
I'm gonna fly in for it you are yeah you
want to go yeah I have to go now but
yeah I'll go [__] yeah let's do it um
yeah I'll go and uh I'm going I think
you guys are going to the Motocross on
Sunday yeah no uh with John shahii are
you guys doing that thing I'm doing
Nitro Circus I'm Nitro Circus tomorrow
I'm going to go oh it's tomorrow it's
tomorrow in Anaheim yeah yeah I actually
I'm meeting Trump tomorrow morning for
breakfast on his plane wow his plane is
landing here we're gonna have breakfast
on his plane then I'm jumping on our
plane and going to uh to Nitro Circus oh
that's going to be fun yeah I wanted to
be over there what does Trump have for
breakfast you think have you had
breakfast I'll tell you tomorrow okay
okay tell you tomorrow all right what uh
what would your walkout song Be You
think if you were a fighter oh [__]
there's so many good ones to choose from
I sort of lived vicariously through the
through the athletes over the last you
know however many years cuz I picked a
lot of the songs for a lot of these guys
to walk out to yeah do some of them just
not want to pick it some of them don't
even give a [__] what could care less
like they could die they're not even
going to know what music's on the way
there nope oh damn yeah most most of
them didn't even care in the early days
and yeah you can't die on it with
Hillary Duff when you're going to the
[__] War yeah no most of the music
that that was picked back in the day was
done by me and um but the but the
walkout song's important it's a big deal
it's one of the things that if if you're
not a big star already and the song
comes on and people connect with the
song and like it they're like oh who is
this guy it's a big deal yeah Bobby
green I think does it pretty well I
noticed he'll kind of change his up and
he brings so much energy you know but I
think you can feel his energy when he's
coming in uh porier has that James
Brown you know some of these Fighters
come up with songs that I would never
dream of could be a cool
walk-in song and yeah the walk-in song
is is a fun but very important part of
the the live event yeah I think so man I
want to yeah and I want to say too man
just your bravery and doing and keeping
things going during the pandemic it
changed everything it gave a lot of
people a feeling like that there was
still somebody that could do something
different it gave a lot of people a
feeling that like um Everybody wasn't
subject to uh kind of like the
privatized tyranny that's kind of gone
on yeah you know and um I agree with you
and man it made it made me so much more
of an involved fan dude that's awesome
well I appreciate it it listen the
pandemic never made sense to me and and
again because of my close relationship
with Abu Dhabi you know I knew over
there they they were doing testing and
they were doing all this stuff I'm like
if they can do it why can't we do it
over here yeah and why couldn't we
create you know this space you know they
ended up calling them the bubble but
this space where you know everybody was
tested you knew everybody was clean and
we couldn't put on an event we did it in
Jacksonville we did it in Abu Dhabi and
you know I'm one of these guys I love
this country I I I love America uh this
country's obviously been very good to me
my family and uh a lot of my friends and
employees we don't just [__] roll
over and hide in this country man this
whole pussification of America and
everybody you know [__] scared of
everything and whatever I was like if
this is as bad as they think it is
or they're saying it is [__] dead
anyway yeah we're going to die you don't
want to die yeah just wearing a mask
they can't even see your face yeah dying
a mask hiding in your house oh hell no
so what do you think your walkout song
would be look can it just be the cult
sure I do the cult I do the cult uh I do
the cult sheel
Sanctuary um or listen you know when you
can never go wrong with the walkout song
ACDC yeah you never go wrong with
ACDC I'm trying to think of an ACDC song
I'm a little bit Back in Black yeah back
for those about the rock For Those About
to Rock oh that's the [__] my brother
used to beat the [__] out of need all
that music exactly some good ass
whooping music oh I still I have a
floating rib that was originally not
floating uh because of half of aliceon
Chain's second
album
CH ohud G and chaines fan bro we would
lose bro one time I go over to Perry
frell's house right I relapsed first of
all I relap laughs at a one-year-olds
birthday party so obviously I've had
some tough times but um I A friend of
mine who's in jail now I think but at
the time he had a child a friend of mine
had a party at Perry frell's house CU he
had a nice home and it was a
one-year-old birthday and I go in and I
didn't know who Perry farell was I'd
listen to him you know I just couldn't
recognize him right and then I'm just
there's this dude kind of just mumbling
around by this big bookcase and I go
over there I'm [__] talking to the
dude about these different books and
ended up being him anyway the story is
anticlimactic but yeah I met him at a
one-year-old birthday party and neither
one of us knew the child which I think
also made it weird and we talked about
that a
little it's weird to be at a really
small kid's birthday and pretend that
that he's bigger or something right you
know um what is that Nick chenade oh
that's chenade yeah yeah yeah that that
that's that that's a good one you know
it was fascinating too because a big
chenade big chenade fan and uh I
actually didn't go to my high School
10-year reunion because sheno Conor was
playing at the Hard Rock I went to see
sheno Connor instead and um then to meet
her and go through this whole thing with
Connor and she was such a incredible
performer and had such a great voice and
I think this kind of goes to what you
were talking about about putting
yourself out there you know she ripped
up that picture of the Pope on Saturday
Night Live that night and she got
[__] just attacked by everybody I
mean everybody just started coming after
her and she got beat on for so long that
she actually got to the point where she
would have terrible anxiety when she
would go out and try to perform wow so
leading up to that Connor walk out it
was uh we didn't know if it was going to
happen or not happen live even though
she was there and we had done the deal
with her to come but um yeah I adored
her she was a really good person I liked
her a lot and uh sad to see her go but I
was a huge nade fan did you like give
her a pep talk before is there any kind
of communication like that 100% I
absolutely did yeah I can imagine I can
totally relate to what you're saying is
if if the you think the media especially
or people some people are on your side
and how they would be so scary
especially if you're a singer to go out
there yeah it's it's listen when when
you're out in the public and whatever
the thing is with me is I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] give a [__]
what anybody says or what anybody thinks
I have this mindset I know exactly who
the [__] I am I have my circle of people
that I hang around with who know me and
know what I'm about and whatever and uh
anybody else who doesn't like it or
doesn't want to too [__]
bad okay were you always like that do
you think always like that wow I was
always like that CU that's the part that
I think these days it gets a little bit
harder to create like I mean I I I work
for myself right and so um it's nice to
have your own space where you don't have
to answer anybody you have to answer to
advertisers sometimes but at this point
you can also sell direct to Consumers
you can say [__] card advertisers if
you need to I will never ever answer to
a [__] Advertiser never yeah I've
been through it yeah believe me yeah
listen this is really easy [__]
solution pay me what you owe me and you
go your way and I'll go mine pretty easy
[__] Solution that's it yeah yeah
don't you can't ever let these these
[__] people hold you hostage or to
you know try to change who you are or
what you stand for or um try to try to
uh determine how you're going to run
your business yeah [__] that [__] do you
think that that is becoming more the
common place or that it got to be the
common place and now we're getting out
of that I think it it needs to be the
common place you
cannot you cannot be held hostage by
advertisers I mean uh Dave Chappelle has
this great um
comedy thing that he was doing and he
says uh you know everybody asked me why
I don't have a tennis shoe and you know
I've been offered tennis shoe deals you
know I don't have a tennis shoe because
as soon as you do something they don't
like they take the tennis shoe away you
it's gone and all that [__] and you know
what I mean he's right yeah that's why I
don't [__] with Hollywood a lot man I
don't do a lot of [__] they say come do
this come be in the movie The guy calls
me [__] Ricky Furley or whatever
calls me hey you want to be in the you
know dopesick 11 or whatever the [__]
movie is I don't give a dude no I don't
want to [__] I don't want if they I
don't want them to be able to write an
article to be say hey we took this away
from this guy because he said this yeah
I don't [__] need any of that [__]
100% and they only came to ask me once I
started doing my own thing anyway so
[__] them sorry man I'm obviously angry
about that but um but thanks for some of
the yeah you're not wrong you're right
yeah there's a lot of that energy in the
world that way it's got to be 100% man
you let these people come in and and and
you know these people are paying to be a
partner with you to to to put their
logos with you and be with you until
something go you find out who's with you
and who's not when the [__] hits the fan
yeah you know what I mean I say this all
the time it happened with me and my my
employees during coid right during Co
they're laying people off and whatever
we didn't [__] lay anybody
off didn't you didn't you negate some of
your salary or something what did you
guys do no I said I would but okay I
said we're going to go through this
we're not laying anybody off we're going
through this yeah and um you know every
Christmas party I get up on stage and
tell my [__] team how much I love
them and how important they are to me
and then the scariest Time In Our
Lifetime uh hits and I'm like hey yeah I
love you guys so much I'm G to [__]
lay you off some of you have been with
me 10 15 20 years th I'm one of these
guys the whole [__] ship goes down
together or not at all we're all [__]
sinking me included or we don't at all
you know and and uh you know that
doesn't exist in in this world that we
live in today everybody's just so so
easy to pull the trigger and let go of
some of their people and no it's
something good I need to hear that too
you know I'm just as my business grows
I'm become more of a boss I never wanted
to be a boss how how do you do this how
do you do this without these two I don't
right but I yeah and now that you said
how Christmas how do these two do this
appreciate without you right you're a
[__] team I think we've realized that
more this year I think but it's become a
Learning lesson for me as a ball you
know it's like you think like I need to
just hold on but you really need to let
go and let others help you're a you're a
team you what you do is when you run a
successful [__] business you do it by
building a really good team around you
you know and uh I I have you're Lu you
have a lot of great employees man I got
the best team in the world man 350
unfuckingbelievable people when I said
we're [__] storm of the beach we're
going definitely dude nobody [__]
said no there is no experience man when
I go to the UFC fights it's like the
whether it's the assistants or your
directors or um the guys who are opening
the cage door you look over and there's
like some hero years there's David Spade
or there's Mel Gibson or there's Joe
burrow it's like you have all of just
like and it just feels like you're in
this fun [__] family that's a little
bit mentally unhinged right I'm not GNA
say that okay no you're not wrong yeah
this yeah this family's had some [__]
domestic disputes all right but they uh
but it just dude it feels so much fun
when I leave the event I miss that I
miss the people that you work with just
as much as I miss the action that's
awesome I I I love hearing that and and
thank you and and you're not the first
one to tell me that everybody tells me
that anybody who interacts with anyone
on my team and and everybody here is is
smart hardworking the best at what they
do and there's no none of that [__]
you know at the office where there's all
this backstabbing and [__] all this
[__] those type of people we get rid
of immediately yeah you you you don't
last here being that kind of a person
this is a team this is a family and uh
we throw parties here all the time for
all of our employees we we throw
different types of parties like parties
for the for the employees where they can
bring their their spouse or their wife
or whatever then we throw parties where
you can bring your kids because we want
their kids to come and see the place
where their parents work and they want
them to feel you know your parents are
gone at work all the time we want the
kids to look at where they go to work as
a fun place as as a place that's that
that's cool oh Mom and Dad are at work
we love going to their work yeah you
know what I mean oh [__] start a 37
PB weight class dude you know what I'm
saying yeah I mean that's that's out of
line because that's children fighting
but um was it hard for you to learn to
be a boss as your business crew like
what was some of the cuz man even you
just saying this in front of us man it's
important for us to hear because I I I
need to do a better job of it you know
and some of that is just stuff I'm
learning as my business has grown and my
responsibilities and not feeling like I
need to really try to do everything
myself you know I can be a better uh
boss and employ and and cooworker a lot
of times um it's just powerful you're
saying that in front of us delegating
it's and respecting
people's ability to do stuff sometimes
I'm just I was always so used to doing
things myself growing up 100% you no I
get listen I'm still as successful as
this thing has been and all the stuff
that we do I get here every day at 9:00
and and I'm one of the last guys leave
this building every night still um was
it hard to learn to be a boss like how
did you like have like a role model with
that or did you well I I I had my own
business before this but you know I
obviously wasn't the difference the only
difference in in coming to the UFC was
you
know the size you know being a global
company and obviously the finance side I
mean you know I went from dealing with
hundreds of thousands of dollars to deal
in with hundreds of millions of dollars
so that that's the the difference um but
you know Finance is not my [__] thing
we have a very strong Finance team and
you know one of the things I hated the
most in in being in this business was
[__] budget meetings man yeah we used
to be in budget meetings you know when
we were getting murdered and we were
losing money we were in budget meetings
for [__] it felt like days and uh
that was the only not fun part of the
business for me and uh now where we are
now I only do the fun [__] I only do the
[__] that I really love to do and and I
stay completely focused on which is
making sure the production the live and
in house production is [__] perfect
um uh finding new
Talent uh putting on the best fights we
can possibly put on and start building
those are those are the things that I
really focus on um so more more
marketing I don't [__] with finances at
all yeah good yeah I mean just because
you like to gamble you know know and
because [__] I I do too man so you
know I [__] I'm on some site now I
can't even get my money out of the
[__] thing like Jesus dude online
gaming is is a little is a little it's a
little strange isn't it I respect them
and we're happy that they advertise but
it's also it's a little obtuse sometimes
I'm an old school Brick and Mortar uh
you know sit at the table and play kind
of guy oh yeah I'd rather not be able to
pay my tab and have two [__] Italians
beat the [__] out of me you
know cuz at least it [__] evens out
you know at least in the morning I wake
up I'm like oh [__] I deserve it you
know it's like you you know it's
physically part of you feel like like it
makes sense um what if I said that the
perfect gift does exist and I'm talking
to you about manscape that's right they
want to baby them balls baby they want
to help you out down there manscapes
brand new performance package 5.0 Ultra
featuring the new lawn mower 5.0 watch
all your wishes and and mistletoe kisses
come true if you hanging some mtoe off
that d
boy look nice when you're getting
naughty by going to manscape.com and use
code Theo for 20% off that's right that
lawn mower 5.0 Ultra body trammer
o and that weed whacker weed whacker 2.0
nose and ear trimmer get in there boy
you can't smell you can't hear I'll Jack
you out baby I'll get you tidy they'll
do it from manscaped 20% off in free
shipping with the code theom
manscaped.com is possible that's right
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code theom
manscaped get your jingle balls ready
for the holidays you know you you should
have confidence when you're uh buying
tickets to an event sometimes you go to
an event and you get there and they it
says oh we we did we we didn't have
tickets for this but we give you tickets
to this we got agenda reveal Willie
Nelson reenactment and you're like what
all right you know but you're not happy
game time they won't do it to you it's
the fast and easy way to buy tickets for
all the sports music comedy and Theater
events near you game time has last
minute tickets Flash deals Zone deals
easy to find and buy tickets for every
kind of event in your area you can see
the view from your seat before you buy
so you know exactly what to expect when
you arrive and you have Allin prices up
front so there's no rig a roll at the
last minute download the game time app
create an account and use code weekend
for $20 off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code week n d for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed the holidays are the
busiest time of the year it's true
there's traffic and there's bustling and
there's you see somebody can't do
nothing and you got to help them and you
put a down a little Jingle Bell on them
if you are shipping orders and your
business is scaling it's getting busier
ship station is the answer that's right
ship station whether you're shipping
from your house or multiple
warehouses they can increase your
holiday
profitability ship station has
effortless integration anywhere you sell
online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and more ship station's robust
automations and Reporting make scaling
easy as your business grows you can save
thousands on shipping costs get
discounts of up to 84% off USPS and UPS
rates just go to shipstation.com and use
code Theo today and sign up for your
free 60-day trial that's shipstation.com
code Theo make ship happen is it hard
for you guys to pick sponsors I know you
guys have a new sponsorship you guys
have new sponsorship with Bud Light
right yep but is it do people like do
companies come and do like shark tank
for you kind of to present the brand
yeah kind of so um you know the UFC is
at a point now where you know guys come
to us and and and want to pitch their
their brands or whatever it is to to uh
advertise with us
and recently you know I I've become very
involved in the uh on the sponsorship
side so you know I I meet with these
guys and and uh you know I just did a an
interview the other day with with the
media at the scrummed lap and it's just
I'm at a point now where in my life in
my career I want to be with people that
I'm aligned with people that you know
yeah it's it's not it's not just about
the money it is about the money because
it's a sponsorship deal but it's not
just the money not going to go for not
going to take a a bigger offer if it
isn't something that I am aligned with
and don't 100% believe in [__] yeah dude
good for you it's nice to be in that
space you know and I bet we can probably
all be there but I think some of it's
fear but um yeah I had a business guy
you're just talking about this were
y'all about in life you have to have no
fear you have to have no fear you have
to you have to believe in who you are
and what you do and just go [__] get
it yeah don't be afraid to tell somebody
no [__] water guy wants to you know
wants to do a deal with you and the
money looks good but there's certain
things about that you're not into [__]
them [__] don't do it the right thing
there will be another one exactly and
and somebody that you're more aligned
with when you look at at these type of
things no different than a relationship
if you're going to get into a
relationship with somebody right imagine
if you had to had to drop a contract
yeah with some woman Aqua he say we're
gonna no some woman we're going to be in
a relationship six years yeah oh yeah
you got to you you you have to be
aligned and you have to it has to be
somebody that you can be in a
relationship with for six years yeah you
don't want to be three years in and be
like Oh I'm still drinking Rhonda you
know or or you don't you don't want to
be three years in and be like Oh I'm
still drinking Britney you well what
happens too is I didn't mean to say
Rhonda so cuz I know she's a fighter
here I just don't want there to be any
weird energy okay there won't be anyway
good Ronda was amazing actually one of
the greatest one your favor I know
that's what Nicole said she said that
all time she named somebody else
favorites but go on I'm sorry um I
[__] this up [__] man sorry no you you
you don't want to be in a relationship
with for a long time the co thing it's
like you know you you think you're in
this business with with uh you know
whatever uh product it is is and the
[__] hits the fan like that that's when
you find out who everybody really is
including some of your sponsors oh yeah
do you know what I mean so you get you
know you're in the the sponsorship deal
and the phone's ringing every day you're
picking it up and and and you know they
don't like that you're doing this they
don't like that you're going through
coid this is irresponsible you man get
the [__] out of here get the [__] out of
here you know what I mean you just it's
just when you do a sponsorship deal with
somebody you have to look deep into who
they are and you know who's running the
company who's making the decisions and
are you aligned yeah I love that man
yeah because we had Robert Kennedy Jr on
and we had a company call or a couple
companies call after that and say yeah
just stuff about him we're not
advertising on this episode my
advertisers like you guys need to take
the episode Down you know and uh and and
we ended up and what's wrong with him
nothing nothing guy's [__] brilliant
are smart [__] for seven years great
guy I mean a neat man right I I've never
met him yeah I've only watched his stuff
and and you got this whole Democrat
Republican [__] all this crazy
[__] he's a [__] Democrat yeah
right but now they hate him just because
he doesn't believe like he's a Democrat
with common sense right yeah right he's
like an old school Democrat yeah and
smart guy whatever let me tell you this
let me [__] tell you this
this is
America you can [__] have whoever you
want on your podcast you can do whatever
the [__] you want to do imagine a
sponsor that's sponsoring you calling
you and telling you that you can't have
this guy what sponsor did it
um I let me think and I'm not afraid to
name him I don't know if I remember I
really don't right I don't know if I
believe you but okay that's fair um but
I really don't know if I remember
imagine and this happened to me too this
this happened to me I posted a video for
Trump right on my personal social media
and one of our big sponsors called and
said take that down you know what I said
go [__] yourself yeah you vote for
whoever you want to vote for and I'll
vote for whoever I want to vote for
that's how this works I don't even care
who you're voting for it's none of my
[__] business but [__] you yeah don't
ever [__] call me and tell me who to
vote for yeah yeah yeah I think a lot of
people feel in fear these days you know
a lot of people feel in fear that if
they don't vote for certain people
they're going to lose their jobs I mean
it's Hollywood for example think about
how [__] crazy that is it sounds
insane it sounds just like well it'll
keep happening unless more people stand
up for themselves and give them the [__]
you response well I'm GNA tell my
sponsors right now if you don't if you
don't like what I [__] have on I'll
tell you exactly what I'll do I'll end
my deals and I'll just sell direct to
Consumer for a lower price because the
people will support you you know that
well listen man you can't it's like this
whole BD light deal you know people are
talking [__] now sellout and all the
[__] that that they'll [__] say
believe me I'm the furthest [__]
thing from a sellout yeah budlight is
the right move for me they're exactly
who I want to be with right now and uh
we are very aligned as far as core
values go you know what I mean 65,000
Americans they employ yeah that right
there should be enough 65,000 Americans
are employed there why you want to put a
bullet in that brand off of one [__]
thing how about you go back and look at
all the good things they've done yeah
right a good point and where they really
stand and what they really believe in
they take care of veterans they they
they take care of veterans families and
First Responders families who have
fallen and the list just goes on and on
almost a billion dollars a year with us
Farmers wow that alone is the reason you
should be drinking [__] budlight yeah
so [__] I I look deeper than just
[__] you know oh they did this
[__] can with whoever I don't give a
[__] about that
it's they've already they're showing
right now that they're coming with me
and they want to be aligned with me
those of you that are hardcores some of
you guys are fanatical on this [__] that
should be your you know you guys think
you're all looking for an apology I
ain't going to [__] apologize to you
yeah [__] that just cuz some risky fella
you know just cuz some you know and they
had 2500 influencers that day they gave
everybody their own can I know they did
I knew that [__] I'm like they just gave
a can everybody nobody's paying
attention if if I don't know where I'm
at sexually I could probably use a drink
you
know that's honestly how I feel dude
that guy's having that guy's having the
toughest day that's [__] you can't
decide what union to [__] be in bro
that's a [__] issue dude that's a big
issue to me but um no I think look man I
think it's important and you know what
it makes me think I don't look and see
who cuz we're in a place now where I can
choose the advertisers that I want and I
never thought about that before I never
have until just now and I could I can
look at advertisers and see if they have
some of the same beliefs and values that
I do 100% you know and it's important
and that is how you start to build back
things the other way I wish and it makes
it fun whoever you are and whatever you
believe in when you align yourself with
people not just the people that work for
you and around you but the sponsors that
you're with yeah it just makes
everything so much more fun you enjoy
your job you love what you do every day
and there's no [__] nobody's [__]
calling you going you know hey don't
have [__] Kennedy on your show hey go
[__] yourself [__] tell me who I'm
going to have on my show yeah go John F
[__] yourself that's what I'll tell ex
there you go exactly dude it's crazy
because Lee Harvey Oswald went to the
same middle school as me which is pretty
wild but um anyway I don't know why I
told you robt Kennedy's a smart guy and
he's you know he's a great man he's an
environmentalist first of all and he
helped clean up our environment right
he's he grew up raising homing pigeons
and he has this great story about him
and his friends when they were kids they
would put they would give the Homing
pigeons to a to the train conductor
right and they would be like okay take
these to Virginia or whatever and let
them off at the same time you have to
promise us and whoever gets back to the
roost first that's who wins right so
imagine that game with your buddy you're
just [__] sitting there waiting for a
pigeon to come in you know just the
guy's fascinating right that's some rich
people [__] right there oh dude that is
[__] Rich bro something flies by us
dude somebody's [__] gunning it down
bro you know um but uh we actually had a
couple Brothers bu us grilling up a dove
one time our neighbors and uh and I
never eaten Dove but it was pretty good
but um but Robert's a fascinating guy
but that's how he started caring up
caring about vaccinations was he's an he
cared about the environment outside of
us so then he started care about the
environment inside of us right um so it
all makes perfect sense but um but yeah
I love the guy um what about so when you
deal with like how has it been harder
because you guys are part of William
Morris right I work with them right they
pretty woke company right is it woke is
woke can be yeah yeah I think it's woke
Morris entertainment or something you
know it should be anyway but um yeah
they're [__] woke they're always
crazy we had Tucker Carlson on the other
day and they're all [__] I'm sure you
know or whatever putting on their maxi
pads but um I love Tucker too yeah
Tucker's [__] fascinating is dude
awesome I'm actually going to dinner
with him here in the next uh next few
weeks yeah he's it was interesting I
didn't know what it would be like you
know he looks like a guy that you know
uh gets dressed at Johnston and Murphy
in the airport every day you know but um
he was really really cool yeah he's a
great dude smart guy too really smart
yeah it was fun I I don't judge people
by their politics or or their race or
their religions or any of that [__]
there's uh you're either a douchebag or
you're not a douchebag and and if you're
a douchebag I want nothing to do with
you if you're a good person I don't care
who you vote for what who you sleep with
or what religion you are I don't care
about any of that [__] sh is it um how
much have you learned about different
cultures and ethnic ethnicities just
having your cuz dude you bring in
there's people with flag sometimes and I
got to look them up you know yeah no
it's true that's funny it's amazing
though it's like I learned about uh
Ecuador from um Cheeto Vera right I
didn't know about it but next thing you
know I know about it I get to talk with
him it's like from
eador yeah yeah thank God I got that
right too because that [__] Flag I
got it wrong I questioned it um Cheo ver
is a great dude um fasc but it is it's
it's it's it's
there will be nights that we'll be
sitting there by the octagon and I trip
out I grew up a big Bruce Lee fan right
and when you watch Enter the Dragon it's
basically the premise is this this
fanatical guy got all these people from
around the world who were supposed to be
the best martial artists in the world he
brings them to one place to fight um
that's a movie yeah Enter the Dragon
with Enter the Dragon I've heard of it
you never saw Enter the Dragon I never
saw
it you need to watch that tonight when
you go home all right yes sir Enter the
Dragon so this guy brings them all to
this island the guy ends up being you
know bad guy he's corrupt or whatever
and Bruce Lee kills him sorry to ruin
the movie for you but uh I'll still
watch it some nights I'll sit there and
I'll think about it I got I got this guy
from China fighting a guy from
Kazakhstan I got this guy from Brazil
fighting a guy from France you know what
I mean and it's like it is it's like I
grew up loving Enter the Dragon in that
whole concept now here you are doing it
doing it it's yeah it's pretty [__]
cool dude laughter and left hooks says a
universal languages I think it's true I
agree because it's crazy imagine two
guys that can't even speak to each other
then you put Keith Peterson in between
him as the mediator and no offense I
love Keith he came to a show in New
Jersey he knows I love him and uh but if
that's the [__] moderator and then
they can't even speak but they're
fighting it's really it's kind of a
beautiful dance the whole thing is a
beautiful day have these people from
different parts of the world right and
they're training and they're trying to
become the best mixed Mar martial arts
they can be and somebody on the other
side of the planet is doing the same and
we can actually put them together to see
who is the best it's [__] awesome
dude that's got to be so high man it's
awesome have you had trouble do you ever
have trouble like I have trouble A lot
of times feeling proud of myself is
something I've had trouble withes has
that ever been something you've dealt
with does that make any sense when I ask
you that I'm never proud of myself I I I
always look at things like we're not
even close people ask me all the time do
you ever look around and say oh wow look
at I'm always like what's next what's
next what's next yeah why do you think
that is do you think because I'm I'm
that way too it's hard for me to feel
kind of where I'm at sometimes because I
always have some Vision or something you
know that needs to be done yeah do you
think that comes because I noticed it's
a commonality amongst some some folks do
you think there's any have you able to
get in touch with any of that and think
about that at all no I don't give a [__]
yeah I just keep [__] I just keep
plugging I just keep plugging man
there's just so much more work to be
done I just want to do as much as I can
do yeah until I can't do it anymore yeah
dude I I'm so thankful that you said
that about the advertisers because I
don't even think about it we advertise
for a lot of companies right and we can
have an effect on how well they do we've
helped build some big Brands and to
think that I should know who what their
some of their thoughts are and their
beliefs are so that I can align them
with mine [__] that's cool that's
something that's a way that I can help
contribute towards in the world and have
fun doing it you know you help build
their business they help build yours
it's a really it should be a great
relationship and it should be a good
experience for everybody involved yeah
um but I can tell you from experience if
you end up with the wrong one there's
nothing fun about it and actually you
you end up in a in a bad relationship
it's like any other bad relationship
between you and a woman or whatever it
could be
a bad relationship yeah have yall
struggled with I mean it happens I guess
it's happened a couple times but yeah um
oh pelaton was the we just got an update
um P was the B was the people who wanted
an ad out pelaton and meanwhile you have
RFK so pelaton yeah what do they sell
[__] bik the stationary bikes yeah
dude pelaton sell stationary bikes and
they got a problem with Robert [__]
Kennedy [__] you pelaton what who the
[__] are they yeah first of right are
you [__] kidding me yeah yeah [__]
pelaton calling bitching about Robert
Kennedy yeah dude you want to go nowhere
who who's the CEO of
pelaton I want to see this [__] guy I
want to see this [__] lamb dude hey
you know what gets you further than
pelaton hitchhiking okay how about that
dude Barry mcth this [__] weener
snitel huh let's see Barry McCarthy oh
my
god oh oh yeah oh [__] yeah Barry
McCarthy looks like that guy 100% and
look if you're just listening at home
and you're thinking of what he looks
like you're right he looks like a
douchebag yeah dude 100% where's he from
oh yeah he looks like somebody that eats
his own skin a little bit at a time yeah
he is he is
a where is he [__] from he called me
up and said this guy was complaining
about something I'd say oh
[__] San Francisco California there we
go my boy ring a ling dude they've been
giving patons to [__] vagrant that's
why they're not leaving yeah [__] you
pellaton yeah do we have pelons in the
gym are those
pelaton asport no no there's bikes next
to it asport as yeah we're getting rid
of them y we're getting rid of the
pelons yeah and if they ever ma we sorry
he's going to kill himself but we're
getting rid of the pelons look pelons
are out of the gym whoever uses the most
can [__] have them at home but they
can't use them here brother that's what
you do that that's what you do you stop
[__] using their products and you
[__] them yeah and tell them to go [__]
themselves and that's the same thing for
me like if somebody's telling you that
you can't vote a certain way if
somebody's telling you that if your boss
is make a video in [__] blast imagine
that [__] dork yeah [__] picking
up the phone calling you and telling you
that you can't have Robert Kennedy who
is a Democrat by the way you know that
guy's a [__] Democrat right telling
you that you can't [__] have him on
your show who the [__] are you Barry
McCarthy yeah to think you can pick up
the phone and call anybody you sell
[__] stationary bikes for a living
you [__] clown [__] you yeah [__]
them dude god dude and what is he
[__] what is he he's probably
middleweight I'll [__] cut 40 pounds
in [__] that guy is the typical
[__] pompus arrogant [__]
douchebag that I cannot stomach it's
people who don't know yeah it's people
that think they know what it's like
somewhere and they've never even been
there it's a story of a lot of our
country these days but I like this it
gives me it gives me an Avenue to feel
like I can fight back so I appreciate
that you have to fight back yeah you
gonna let that [__] guy tell you what
to do [__] no dude I will cook that
dude's [__] look at this there he is
that that right there tells you exactly
what [__] Barry McCarthy is all about
pellaton just laid off 500 their
employees in their fourth round of cuts
this year y you know what everybody
listening [__] [__] Barry McCarthy
and pelaton okay that that's what a
standup guy Barry is yeah dude and
that's why he a yeah [__] SL off let
off 500 more of his [__] employees
out in his fourth round of cuts yeah and
what's Lamer than watching your husband
get on a bike that doesn't go anywhere
huh what wife is like oh oh I'm so proud
of this guy that's like my dad man right
my uh get borsari in here right now I
need borsari in here yeah get him yeah
is he a bicyclist he has to be if he
isn't why does he look exactly not he's
just he's a workout freak I'm I'm not
bullshitting you you can film us yeah my
my guys are going to take the pelons out
of the gym today I love that dude we're
getting rid of them we're going to go
throw them in the [__] garbage today
I'll be happy to toss him in we're
throwing the patons in the garbage we're
throwing him out of the UFC gym I I'll
be happy to toss him in um what about
when you talk about Star Building you
mentioned earlier and we'll do it we'll
do it I know you're amped and I
appreciate it um do what we're gonna
throw those pelons out oh yeah yeah no
that that's a fact yeah [__] I'm almost
excited now yeah [__] that guy man he
ruin you know what he did he ruin they
ruined my day the advertisers calling
they want it down they want it down they
want there's advertisers are upset they
ruined my [__] day and I was already
having a shitty day that day and they
[__] made it just a nightmare it was
like 7 o'clock at night you got to take
it down and the episode had been up it's
a it's just [__] show but yeah screw
them um you talked about Star Building a
little bit ago right you mentioned it
what is it is there a toughest class or
even gender is it tough to build like
female stars like what is that kind of
like Star
Building so if you look at the contender
Series right I I create lots of
different content to build Stars you got
the contender series you have looking
for a fight The Ultimate Fighter which
was the greatest Star Building uh show
in format of all time and I'm I'm
literally doing that same format right
now with power slab we we bring guys
into a house you find these guys you
bring them into a house they live eat
and sleep and train together and then
compete against each other and what it
does is it it does a few
things while you're you're you know
showing the world who they are on on on
television or online or whatever it is
you're it's also a pressure cooker they
have to deal with pressure and competing
over and over and cutting weight then
there's a camera in their face seven
days a week 24 hours a day it's like
media training at the same time it is
and and what always happens is no matter
what the best always rise to the top it
is fascinating all right so this is
Craig borsari he's my head of I know
Craig he's friends with my my I know his
neighbors yep there you go oh he's Craig
Craig is very friendly with all his an
exceptional guy so uh he was in a
situation where he had Robert Kennedy uh
Jr on his show and an Advertiser called
and told him get rid of that you're not
posting that podcast take it down blah
blah blah because he had Robert Kennedy
on right um it was
pelaton okay do you know who Barry
McCarthy is no Barry McCarthy is the CEO
of pelaton yeah let us see Barry
McCarthy again can we see him again
please we got pictures of you and Barry
McCarthy together actually Craig is that
is that pelons that we have in the gym
we have pelons yeah they're going we're
throwing them out yeah we're getting rid
of them that's Barry McCarthy be on a
treadmill this is the [__] guy that
called and told them to take down the
the the [__] we had an episode does
that look like the guy that would call
him [__] about Robert Kennedy Jr he
does doesn't he who is that [__] a
little like Tim Cook yeah he does huh a
little I don't know who Tim Cook I'm
just agreeing with you um I don't know
him either who's look oh oh Apple okay
are gone they're gone they're going out
today I got to go bike on the road now
yeah y something no you just got to use
the assault bikes now instead yeah huh
those are tougher anyway really tough
Pon it's time to step up if I if I asked
you to guess so he called and he wanted
Robert Kennedy Jr taken down right
threatening him uh on his podcast right
yeah they were about to go public I
think their company was about to go
public or something they're like this
could ruin everything that's what our Ad
Agency said to us they're worried this
could ruin everything it's [__] 8 o00
at night on a Friday or something you
[__] imagine that and uh and they
made us go take an older episode down
because of something he said in recently
in the news or this was like a year and
two years ago maybe where where do you
think Barry lives where do you think
he's from just look at him guess huh and
and listen to the conversation and see
if you can tell me where Barry lives
yeah he probably lives
Craig San Francisco oh [__] ding ding
ding ding ding dude hey you just bar
lives in San Francisco hold on you just
won four
pelons congrats you just won a whole
[__] line of you can line them right
up in your house can't set them up here
in the office so I might as well put
them on my home those are going right in
your house congrats I'll put him in my
you G have a flock of pelons dude isn't
that a band you're G have a flock of
pelons dude that's classic man oh man
all right anyway just had to share that
with you yeah I'm go figure out my new
work go get those bikes sent over to
your house yeah dude and send Barry a
text and tell him thanks thanks dude
that makes you feel empowered honestly
no this is what I do I I like do more of
this bro what I do every day and no bike
helmets either anybody wearing a [__]
bike helmet out there I bet a Barry
wears a helmet when he rides his oh I
bet he wears when he rides his wife
dude you [__] come around me with a
bike helmet dude I would rather get a
concussion and die and be seen in a
[__] bike helmet so that is awesome
anyway um what's it like uh we'll switch
out of the out of this world a little
bit what's it like being a dad you have
a couple children right yeah I got three
I got two boys and a girl was that scary
when you first thought about being a dad
yes very wow what was and you already
having success at that point in your
life because I don't know a ton about
when I bought uh right when we bought
the UFC I had my first son my oldest son
he's 22 now and uh Dana Jun no yeah Dana
Jun yeah andet kid then uh a year as
soon as as soon as uh you could be with
your wife again after being pregnant she
got pregnant again so my boys my boys
are are are uh less than a year apart so
I had two kids right out the
gates yeah it was uh two kids right out
of the gate then then they said after my
wife had a a tubular pregnancy where the
baby gets caught in the tube and the
tube bursts and uh they said she
couldn't have kids anymore so oh we we
we were like whatever and then five
years later she got pregnant with my
daughter just miraculously yeah wow
that's what I call her the miracle baby
yeah and what's something that you like
about each one of your children just
individually or that you admire about
each one of them um
my oldest one is uh is funloving and and
uh you know a great kid that you know
he's like a meat head he plays football
he loves to work out he hangs around
he's in a frat you know at USD and all
of his buddies are fun guys and uh
they're actually having a uh this uh
fraternity uh uh auction you know
they're raising money for the fraternity
next week so I'm going down there and
going to their auction and all that [__]
a beautiful school too then my younger
son is very artistic very talented he
could play any sport he wants to play
he's really good at anything but all
three of my kids are really good Surfers
snowboarders um and and my younger son
loves the skateboard and all that stuff
so he's actually working for a company
that Lorenzo fertita and I own called
thrill one which is thrill one thrill
one we own Ridiculousness on MTV y'all
own that yeah that's our only show yeah
it's basically the Ridiculousness
Network exactly Ridiculousness we own uh
LS skate League uh we own Nitro Circus
and uh Travis pastrano nitr cross oh
nice yeah so he my son works for them oh
he does and then my daughter is 17 so
he's the artistic one that one yeah yeah
yeah and and they're all athletic he's
the artistic one and what about your
daughter what's my cheer she's a
cheerleader oh she is yeah she she's
still in high school she's a junior and
uh just getting her ready to figure out
which college she wants to go to and all
that good [__] is it tougher being a
girl did for you was it easier being a
girl or boy dad did you have any it's
tougher being a girl dad because I
didn't really give a [__] what the boys
did you know they could do whatever they
want she can't do whatever she wants so
you know as a dad you have to sort of
oversee and protect your daughter more
than you did your sons ah interesting
and do that naturally I don't have any
kids but I would like to you know and so
does that naturally just happen in a man
you think if you have a daughter it just
kind of shows up more 100% wow dude I
dated a girl I remember in high school
and her dad was a fireman right and I
broke up with her and he [__] made me
eat like
like probably five hot dogs I remember
he was [__] mad at me because I went
to another event with her and it was
like this weird energy and he [__]
sat there and made me eat as many as I
could it was just hot dogs yeah just
like unlimited Franks man I was I'm I'm
I'm trying to figure this one out so he
just wanted to [__] put me through
something you know and I think putting
somebody through bad [__] pork while
they're sitting there you know it's just
a lot for a you know for for me when I
was a kid you know I didn't have a lot
of Role Models so I think it was a lot
um big Holidays baby
that means big family get together baby
you know that somebody's going to be
hugging but you don't have to spend all
that money on your Thanksgiving spread
without getting something in return with
ibata you can get your turkey and all
your favorite sides for free that's
right starting November 1st for the
fourth year in a row ibata is giving
100% cash back on your Thanksgiving
feast yep just add the offers in the app
to redeem for everything you need to
make your Thanksgiving feast complete
all you have to do is shopy your
favorite retailers and upload your
receipt boom download the ibata app now
and use code Theo to get 100% cash back
on your Thanksgiving dinner starting
November 1st just go to the app store or
Google Play Store and download the free
ibata app and use code t h o That's i b
o TTA in the Google Play or App Store
and use code
Theo have you ever used Google incognito
mode well you're going to hate this as
much as I am evidence shows that Google
allegedly violated the privacy of
millions of Americans by tracking users
even when using incognito
mode if you have used Google's incognito
mode and were unaware that it was still
tracking your information you may
qualify to file a claim just try Morgan
and Morgan's quiz today at forthe
people.com this past weekend to see if
you qualify to join their lawsuit it
takes just under 5 minutes that's right
if you believe your privacy has been
violated while using Google's incognito
mode you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to forthepeople.com
thisp weekend that's forthepeople.com
thisp weekend this is a paid
advertisement this episode is brought to
you by better help
you know I'm mentally
unwell you know that and um what helps
me is better help if your brain is not
well if your brain if you saw your brain
on the side of the road and you have to
pull over and help it that's me better
help can help you that's true this time
of year can be a lot and it's natural to
feel anxiety extra emotion your visiting
family you're visiting step family
you're visiting people you've never even
met and and saying their family and they
could be imposters we don't know if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
theot today to get 10% off your first
month that's better
HP
betterhelp.com
o
better help any new Partnerships or
something that you that you're kind of
excited
about um let me think uh you know the
thr1 stuff that I'm doing love it uh you
know we're having a blast doing that um
you know holler head my whiskey yeah
having fun with that you know I like uh
I like building Brands and I I love
running businesses and more importantly
I'm like addicted to winning I love to
win I love to to get out there and take
um these
Niche uh you know Brands and and and
blow them up and make them big yeah I
know I'm friends with John shahii right
and you are too man he's I love Shahi a
love love the both the brothers the ne
boys uh that's that's my it's your squad
that's my it's my squad they keep you
young I bet they keep you connected to
stuff probably well you know how I got
turned on to them was from my oldest son
Dana during Co he says D dad I want to
show you something he took me down the
movie room and showed me elk boys oh
yeah and I said yeah I get it I get it
and then crazy enough organically they
reached out to me during Co and wanted
to go to fight Island so that was how we
met and we became super tight I'm I do
anything for them yeah yeah John's been
an exceptional uh new friend to me in
the past year and a half he's a neat guy
he's inspiring he's fun he's creative he
works hard 100% um do you is there any
new places you're looking to [__] get
this thing to happen like you thinking
about do doing like you know UFC on top
of killamanjaro UFC you know the
Thriller in Manila do you guys think of
redoing anything like that my next big
project that I'm working on right now is
the sphere I want to do the sphere on on
Mexican Independence Day and literally
create and put on the greatest live
sporting event anyone has ever seen yeah
that's my next big project how much fun
is it when Brandon Moreno comes into the
ring it's fun isn't it it's awesome yeah
him and uh it's so fun the the the whole
uh Mexico thing and these Mexican
talented kids yeah I've been working on
this for for 22 years wow that's finally
starting to come to fruition it's so
cool man it's I just yeah I love it when
he comes to the ring um yeah I've met so
many neat people and been inspired by so
many people from your sport Dustin
porier and I are close friends you know
and it's been special like he's like a
real friend to me he's inspired me so
many times when I want to give up I
remember things that he says or other
Fighters say it's it's interesting the
amount of inspiration that that a lot of
people get from your sport um
oh do you ever think about yeah how is
the relationship with WME is it good
very good yeah yeah very good you know
Ari is uh Ari's a maniac man a maniac in
in a good way he he is like a [__]
serial entrepreneur and do you guys have
that in common he's super [__] smart
and the in the fact that you know when
we sold one of his big things was that I
couldn't go so at one point the fatita
sat down with me and they were like cuz
I thought we were just going to move on
and go we were going to go do whatever
next and they were just like listen this
is really good for all of us and this
and that you know you got to stay
nobody's going to buy this thing unless
you stay yeah so you know in the
beginning I I had a hard time with it uh
because I you know I didn't want to sell
selling not Lorenzo was done Lorenzo was
ready to move on and walk and uh I
didn't want to so we got in with Ari
Ari lets me run the businessman and just
you know if I need help on on something
like hey I I need this connection or I
need this or that he can make all that
[__] happen or's that guy like you want
to meet the [__] I want to talk to
the to the [__] uh Ronnie president
of [__] India or whatever the [__] he
can get that guy on the phone and and
get the ball rolling um dang yeah no
AR's awesome he's been a other than
being in business with the fertitas I
couldn't have landed with a with another
better partner than [__] Ari he
really is uh awesome I love him is it
hard to fend off because I know you I
know so you like to gamble is it hard to
keep gambling out of and I bet on on
fights uh on UFC fights online is it how
is there a point where gambling or the
the the odds makers try to come and
infiltrate the actual outcome of sports
no does that make any sense that
question yeah yeah I get it talking
about like Point shaving and [__] like
that happens which would be hard in your
sport I think cuz these guys have so
much individual pride and it would be so
obvious 100% we just had an we we the
problem that we have it just happened
recently is Insider information is the
is the bigger problem these guys inside
these camps oh yeah the guy gets hurt
like Chase Sherman as a list or whatever
no defitely do I love Chase Sherman and
that was just joke chase you know um oh
suspend ma coach James Krauss worked
with offshore Sports B ah so he knows
what's going on so he's trying to bet oh
so
he knows what's going on so he lets
these offshore guys know yeah this guy's
goingon to fight and he tore his ACL or
something like that this happened it did
yeah this just happened recently and uh
that's the closest thing to you know
right but there's no more about Insider
information but these guys the thing
that's so [__] stupid is when you
start when money starts coming in on a
guy these these these these guys know
they they know man they they they know
the uh the gambling world inside and out
so if anything's fishy then they end up
launching an investigation yeah and
they're going to get you and guess what
whatever you made on that bet is not
[__] worth going to you've seen me
say this before it's out the federal
[__]
prison you ain't going to the [__]
white collar crime place over here
you're going to [__] federal prison
yeah you can't people have people be
like what are you in for you know and
you're like Paulo Costa in the third
round right you know it would just be it
wouldn't be as like you know and I love
pooc Costa that's no but it's like you
can't have that be what you're in for in
a [__] serious there's a big
difference when you talk about certain
crimes but this one is is a federal
[__] crime oh because it's gambling
and you go to federal prison that's
that's some real [__] yeah oh yeah I
wouldn't like it um what about uh and
just one more question so but it does
that happen to sports where they get
compromised you think like does that
make any sense when I'm trying and I'm
not saying that no I mean it's a great
question it's it's something that how
many people have ever said to you oh my
god the NFL's so shady this Happ you
hear that because you hear that a lot
more now the Patriots just beat the
bills right and the and the bills were
10 and a half Point favorites you know
it's stuff like that that makes people
go crazy Detroit just got killed you
know one of the best they were five- one
or Five-0 I don't know what they were
but it's just all that type of [__] is
what made me stop you know you know I'm
a [__] Gambler I love to play
Blackjack yeah I don't Sports bet I do
not Sports oh was there a bet that took
you out of it or just that kind of stuff
you know how people say I threw a little
money on the on the game for fun there's
nothing [__] fun about betting on a
game it is the the biggest sweat roller
coaster of all [__] time man and and
it it won't be fun or make you happy it
makes you [__] miserable so you like
to know that the so with Blackjack you
know the outcome pretty quick so you
don't like that long waiting there's no
doubt about it and you
know you get in there and and and uh
it's just more fun I'm actually hands on
and actually playing the [__] game
you know when you sit there and just
watch a [__] game and watch this
whole thing unfold and and lose your
money there's absolutely nothing fun
about or these guys that will do these
parlays yeah I got an 18 parlay and
every [__] team wins and then you
lose the last the last [__] game on
the parlay right yeah and you bet $10
and it would have paid you $10 million
if you [__] won the thing and now you
spent two days watching it too now your
kids are eating [__]
coffee yeah that [__] is [__] heing
dude um what about like uh was there a
fighter that retired and it just kind of
broke your heart because you just or and
it could be more than one maybe I mean I
I know you have probably have great
relationships and unique relationships
with all of them um but was there one
that like is it hard not to get attached
to some of them 100% especially in the
early days we were like a big family I
mean it was like everybody knew
everybody I mean back when you go back
to Chuck Liddell Matt Hughes Rich
Franklin you know I mean that whole
group back then I mean these people
would come to my house for Christmas and
Thanksgiving and you know holidays and
things like that and then you had to go
up there and watch them fight and and it
was tough and and Ronda Rousey Ronda and
I are super close and um that was a
tough one I would say the toughest
retirement for me because usually when
it's time for them to retire I'm happy
for them to retire it's it's over you've
accomplished everything that you could
possibly accomplish why keep doing this
um khabib was a tough retirement yeah
you know cuz I think khabib had so much
more to offer and and so much more to
accomplish um but I think when his dad
passed away it kind of sucked the the
fun out of it for him and and he was
done plus he made so much [__] money
he never has to do anything ever again
oh yeah he could buy his own rock quarry
over there where you know and no offense
I don't know where they're at but I know
and it gets pretty you know um you know
uh Paleolithic and some of those areas
um I don't know if we have anything else
to talk about man yeah one thing you
said that kind of reminded me was I
remember when when Trump was running for
office and Bill bich that asked him
about him and he said that's my friend I
support my [__] friend you know like
whatever you guys think about it is fine
like because he wrote a letter to him
telling him congratulations for running
I think was that is that what happened
and um what are you talking about uh it
was when Donald Trump was running for
office right and they and Bill bich had
written him a letter that just said hey
congrats on running for president right
and I think Trump mentioned it and then
the media attacked bich about it but he
said hey that's my friend I support my
friend yeah yeah and people need to be
able to stand up I think it's yeah I
think people a lot of people are in fear
because I'm having breakfast with him
tomorrow on his plane he's my friend
right we talk all the time we talk about
fights he he called me up uh right after
Abu Dhabi and said those rides are great
oh my God the vul uh you know um is yeah
I met him twice at your events man
exactly he's a great guy he's you know
it this is politics are dirty man it's
nasty it's ugly you know and uh like all
the [__] that's going on right with him
right now if he wasn't running they
wouldn't be doing any of this stuff to
him none of this would be happening and
if he wasn't in the lead like he's going
to win the election none of this would
be happening to him right now so yeah it
just it is what it is and and the guy's
always been an amazing friend to me he
and I will be friends for the rest of
our lives yeah yeah I'm I'm glad I got
to meet him that's first president ever
got to meet you know I would support any
of our presidents you know yeah I always
you well I'm that guy too you know I'm I
I'm I'm not volatile over politics man
this is America you can vote for whoever
you want you could be on either side of
the of the political Spectrum I don't
care I don't judge you by your politics
I judge what type of a person you are
yeah yeah and if you think the
government's going to save your life
dude I've always said this me to the
government you they're just a f these
people that want go you want less
government you want them out of your
life you do not want the government and
the government's never going to take
care of you yeah never going to get rich
off the government dude no dude stamp
collections get [__] homie right the
post office is almost out of business
dude have you been to the post office
recently um it's they just tell you how
to get to wherever you want your mail to
go dude I'll say this it's uh yeah
there's nothing tougher than uh there's
nothing more ridiculous than expecting
the government but I think we're in a
weird space now where we're between
the government that we've been used to
and a new kind of privatized communism
almost so I think we're in this weird
space of almost two governments where
one is like a almost a sh like a shadow
well there's a battle going on right now
there's there there's a there's a war
there is going on uh in the government
one that wants to go one way that most
of us don't want to go and one that
wants to keep things the way they are
yeah it might be broken and [__] up
and needs to be fixed but um we're
definitely in that weird place right now
I agree so get off your pelons boys and
let's [__] go to war uh Dan white man
thanks so much dude and just thanks for
uh yeah David Spade got to bring me to a
fight and and you you let me come and
just I appreciate it man your friends
with a lot of my friends and um I'm just
grateful it's been a joy to get to know
people that work in your office and just
everything it's made it's added a lot of
joy to my life well congrats on all your
success man we're happy for you and uh
yeah I'll see you I'll see you at the
next one I'll see you at next power FL
man there you go boom now I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I'm must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to
take